les salariés d'holcim apprennent à
manier la cisaille dans les temps des
nommés au sein du parc naturel régional
de la haute vallée de chevreuse 40
employés volontaires du spécialiste de
ciment fait les 100 ans de leur
entreprise en contribuant à la
sauvegarde de la centaine d'espèces
d'oiseaux
paul blanc ce havre naturel ses
participations à des projets solidaires
et environnementaux est un cadeau
d'anniversaire plutôt original mais
surtout une aide précieuse pour la faune
et la flore du bassin envahi par le bois
ce qu'on veut c'est leur rendre une
certaine fonctionnalités écologiques et
plus particulièrement retrouver un
maximum de d'herbage donc avec toute une
biodiversité flore et faune les insectes
en particulier les salariés d'holcim
travail un peu plus d'un hectare qui
sera ensuite remis en pâturages avec des
poneys rustique pour maintenir le milieu
dégagé c'est aussi l'occasion de se
côtoyer dans un autre univers où la
hiérarchie du bureau est vite oublié
il ya des contrôleurs de gestion il ya
des secrétaires des comptables des
directeurs via un peu tout le monde qui
représentait aujourd'hui dans la nature
donc on est habillé différemment de
d'habitude et c'est fort sympathique
parce qu'on l'a on est vraiment tous à
égalité oui avec le même le même
uniforme
on apprend à manier à cisailler
peut-être même la hiérarchie est
complètement inversée dès fois dans
l'entreprise continue ses bonnes actions
jusqu'au 16 novembre sur d'autres sites
du département mais salariés il
participe dans toute la france